más de un año después la pandemia en el
continente americano particularmente en
el conosur está lejos de mejorar
en ningún lugar las infecciones son más
preocupantes que en américa del sur
donde los casos suben en casi todos los
países en miel y hervir
tanto brasil como argentina estuvieron
entre los 10 países del mundo con el
mayor número de nuevos contagios en la
última semana sin embargo las respuestas
de los gobiernos difieren en brasil que
registró el martes un nuevo récord de
víctimas mortales con cuatro mil
fallecimientos el gobierno sigue sin
imponer mayores restricciones
no aceptaremos esta política de
quedarnos en casa y cerrarlo todo el
virus no se irá a ese virus el virus
como otros está aquí para quedarse
durante toda la vida
es prácticamente imposible erradicar lo
que haremos y hasta entonces ya te a la
bomba de ok
sin embargo los hospitales de las
principales ciudades se encuentran ya
desbordados desde hace semanas y el país
confirmó además la presencia de la
variante sudafricana del virus en su
territorio en sao paulo incluso los
hospitales improvisados están al límite
la ciudad más grande del país anunció
que comenzará a acabar 600 tumbas por
día
en cambio argentina anunció nuevas
medidas restrictivas para frenar los
brotes habrá toque de queda nocturno
durante tres semanas entre la medianoche
y las seis de la mañana se limitará el
uso del transporte público así como las
reuniones sociales y la actividad de
bares y restaurantes
estas medidas de cuidado son
indispensables para bajar la transmisión
estarán vigentes desde las 0 horas de
este viernes 9 de abril y durarán hasta
el 30 de abril venidero
argentina también registró un récord
histórico en este caso de nuevos
contagios con más de 22 mil infecciones
una cifra que augura un camino todavía
largo